ça permet vraiment le ministre de
l'éducation nationale ne vient pas au
collège du clos de pouilly par hasard
200 élèves ont participé l'année
dernière ou dispositifs de voir fait
cette année deux formules possibles une
heure hebdomadaire pour faire les
devoirs en petits groupes
une classe toute entière réunis par
thème assisté par un enseignant tous les
élèves peuvent s'ils le souhaitent
bénéficier du dispositif auquel le
ministre trouve d'autres bienfaits il ya
toute une série d'effets indirects
d'abord apaiser le climat en famille
parce qu'on sait que les devoirs c'est
parfois un sujet d'agacement en famille
mais c'est aussi améliorer la relation
entre les parents d'élèves et le collège
parce que là aussi ça a contribué à un
bon climat les parents comprennent que
le collège et mobilisées pour faire
réussir les enfants donc tous ces buts 1
direction important et donc devoir fait
c'est quelque chose qui fait évoluer nos
collèges au delà du dispositif lui-même
et parents d'élèves constate aussi une
amélioration leurs enfants sont motivés
devienne autonome comme nous
l'expliquent cette mère de famille au
sujet de son fils élève de 5e sylvie qui
réfléchit en fait et qui décide de ce
qui doit faire un travail scolaire
pendant les 2 2 voies le dispositif
devoirs faits concernent la totalité des
collèges publics comme ici au collège du
chapitre à chevaux 20 94 et la vie sont
inscrits soit 35 % des effectifs
une initiative qui place les enseignants
dans un rôle différent mais j'ai pas
évaluer le travail
on évalue le travail c'est un petit peu
comme on l'est réussissent avec les
fiches de suivi un petit peu ce qui se
passe après mais j'ai pas de notes
directement n'y a pas là la sanction de
la note
je pense qu'ils sont conscients que ça
peut être utile de les aider le ministre
de l'éducation nationale souhaite
poursuivre et renforcer l'action du
dispositif de voir fait l'année
prochaine par des moyens supplémentaires